there comes a time in everybody's life
when you have to realize what truly
honestly is important and sometimes in
the world you can see the darkness in
this life the darkness in this world but
today no that is not today not today not
here not now in no way shape or form are
we going to let the darkness of this
world overtake the one true source of
light that we have left in this life yes
it's true I'm talking about PewDiePie
and we must all do our part in this
fight whether we feel like we're a part
of it or not because the truth is this
affects all of us every single one of us
every single one of us needs to fight
harder than we've ever fought before
when the darkness seems overwhelmingly
grim that's when we need to dig deep
that's when we must truly truly dig
harder than you've ever dug before down
in the description there is a link that
goes directly to subscribe to PewDiePie
and I recommend that you go there
immediately right now don't wait don't
hesitate don't do anything that you
wouldn't ordinarily do on a good Sunday
like today except go down in that
description and click that subscription
link to PewDiePie and make sure you do
it fast and make sure you do it now
because there is nothing in this world
more important than what we are doing
here today and I am going to use my one
ability my one talent my one god-given
ability to speak endlessly to make sure
that you understand the importance of
what is happening right here right now
today in the description is a link and a
link was invented long ago when the
internet was just in its infancy oh yes
but with your mouse device you can move
it down there into the description and
you can click on that link and yes lo
and behold you will go and see that you
are now subscribed to PewDiePie and you
will have done your pardon but the fight
doesn't end there
no because the message needs to be
spread as far and wide as possible you
need to know you need to know now that
you can do your part more than just
clicking that subscription button if you
are already subscribed then you need to
know now that you can tell anybody
everybody your neighbor your friends
your family members even your enemies
because even your enemies need to do
something in this fight I remember a
long time ago when I was a child the man
once spoke to me before I even really
understood what he was talking about but
he said to me son someday you will be
called upon you will be called upon and
you will know you will know with a
certainty of a fire of a thousand suns
you will know that you must do your part
and I said me I am but a small boy and I
don't know what my part is but no today
I know and now you know in the
description there is it link that will
take you to PewDiePie's channel where
you can subscribe to PewDiePie do your
part this isn't just about you this
isn't just about me this is about what's
right what needs to be done in this
world this is about respect and I
respect the fact that PewDiePie needs to
have more subscribers than t-series so
go down into that description right now
and click that link do your part if
you're watching this and you're not even
logged into your account on YouTube you
need to go login immediately immediately
without any hesitation without any
waiting you need to log in right now if
you don't have a youtube account you
need to create one you need to create
one right now because never has there
been anything more important than what
I'm talking to you right now ignore what
we did just yesterday what we did just
yesterday doesn't even matter even a
little bit remotely to what we're doing
right here right now today
dig deep look inside yourself see the
true purpose of your life and know that
this right now is the one true calling
of your entire existence this day more
than any other matters
because on this day there might even be
no coming back sorry I'm getting
emotional about this but there might be
no coming back from this one there might
be no coming back from this if you don't
go in the description and you don't
click on that link and you don't
subscribe to PewDiePie right now there
will be no T series will win t series
will win we can't have that not today
not ever I remember something my dad
told me a long ago he took me out in the
woods and he said son one day you'll
have a calling in your life you'll know
you'll know you'll know you don't know
that
PewDiePie wouldn't need you and if you
see anything even remotely related to
something like a T and something like a
series you'll know the face of evil
you know what age I was when he told me
that I was 9 years old I was 9 years old
I had the wisdom and the grace of that
nine year old and I am channeling that
in my 29 year old body today to get you
to know the importance of what we're
doing here so don't hesitate don't wait
click that link in that description
below click it right now it says sub -
PewDiePie arrow arrow www.youtube.com /
user / PewDiePie question mark sub
underscore confirmation equals 1 if you
have to type that into your URL on
whatever browser you're on right now
then do it do it now because there's
never been anything more important than
this you see this number you see this
number this number must always and
forever be above this number but you see
the gap you see that gap that gap is
shrinking that gap has been shrinking
for months now
and we've been trying we've been trying
so desperately hard to fend it off but
we must all do our part sorry my gum I
need to ignore that because there's
something even more important at stake
here the heart and soul of YouTube do we
want to give the heart and soul of
YouTube over to t-series cuz PewDiePie
has it much like the one ring in Frodo
we can't hand it over to the wrong hands
and t-series will lead us down into a
path of darkness and ignorance we can't
have that we cannot have that go in the
description right now sub - PewDiePie
there's a link I couldn't possibly make
it easier for you and I'm telling you
I'm telling you right now everybody
that's just sitting around looking at
this going ha ha ha oh oh oh what a
silly [ __ ] well the only silly [ __ ]
here is you you need to get off your ass
and you need to log into your YouTube
account right now or if you do not have
one you need to make one right now it's
easy it's super super easy just look at
all the bots that are making all fake
accounts apparently it's real easy to
make a youtube account so what excuse do
you have huh you think that BOTS are
smarter than you are you gonna let the
bots beat you or are you better than
that I thought I knew you to be better
than that but maybe I'm wrong maybe I am
wrong maybe I am wrong maybe I am wrong
or maybe I'm not wrong maybe it is you
that is wrong maybe it is t-series that
is wrong you need to do this I can only
do so much
I am one man lusciously handsome that I
am immensely strong immaculately penis
as I am I am only one man I can only do
so much
but together together we can do so much
more
we can do so much more beyond anything
but the fight doesn't just end now you
can't just sorry there goes my Soylent I
can't bother with that right now the
fight doesn't end right now the fight
doesn't end here the fight isn't over
when this livestream ends the fight ends
when victory is secured and victory is
never secured ever not ever dammit my
water bottle I can't deal with that
right now this is too important victory
is never assured you must always be
vigilant
you must always recruit more
nine-year-olds to the cause look back at
your 9 year old self see the person you
were destined to be know what needs to
be done right here right now in that
description click that link subscribe to
PewDiePie immediately you have to for
everyone in this world for everyone
around you for all your family members I
don't want to live in a world where
t-series has more subscribers than
PewDiePie no it can't be happening
let me go back a few weeks when there
was no hope left when there was no hope
left in the entirety of the world there
was nothing there was darkness grim
destitute we were all lost in the wind
alone drifting directionless pointless
our lives meaningless where we go and
you have one man one man stood up and
said no we will not let this darkness
overtake us that man PewDiePie a man
unlike any other tall a staggering 5
foot 10 an immense 155 pounds sometimes
blond of hair sometimes bleached of hair
it never really seems to stay the same
because when you look upon him you see
only the face of beauty now I say to you
now you need to subscribe to that man
cuz he stood up and he said no more and
I'm standing up right now and I'm saying
many many many more to subscribe to
PewDiePie
right now there's a link in the
description below there's an easy easy
link there is no reason that you cannot
click that link there's no reason that
you can't take that link and share it to
everyone you know it is so simple it's a
simple link that goes directly there and
if they're logged in they click on that
link and well baby they subscribe to
PewDiePie immediately quickly rapidly
and it must happen and I hate to be the
guy that wishes ill upon anyone and nay
I hate to be the guy that admonishes
anyone with poor taste but I say to you
now if there is anyone and I don't think
it'd be true but if there is anyone that
is subscribed to ste series at this
juncture in this stream right now look
inside your soul my headphones I can't
deal with that now look inside your soul
question why you subscribe to T series
in the first place and then correct
yourself cuz I don't know what kind of
rash thinking got you to subscribe to T
series in the first place but you need
to click that unsubscribe button
immediately I'm not joking about this
I don't joke about anything ever you
need to go there and you need to
unsubscribe if I could make a link that
could unsubscribe you from T series I
would put it in the description but as
right now YouTube only allows you to
make a link that subscribes you to
PewDiePie
so click that link and then unsubscribe
from T series immediately I can't even
look at you right now I can't look at
anyone that has the Unruh mittened
ability to really think if that's a good
idea but forget about that forget about
that forget about the ridiculousness of
you're poor taste and let's focus on
what really matters when I was a kid
some lady came up to me she might have
been a witch she said to me you son
you're going to need to look into your
future and you're going to need to do
what's right and I said get away from me
old lady who her [ __ ] are you but I
should have listened because I didn't
realize I didn't realize until I looked
in my Twitter feed just this morning and
I saw I saw I saw the tragedy of the
future
I saw what could have been done and I
saw the future that would have happened
if I had just stayed by the wayside and
I said no and I decided that this is the
true path this is the way this is the
light screaming chat right now if you
are subscribed to PewDiePie let it
scream out loud let everyone be known
what must be done go now the link in the
description below click on that link
subscribe to PewDiePie but don't let it
just stop there because everyone must do
their part in this fight everyone there
is no limit to the amount that you can
shout there yes
cry out scream yes yes yes scream cry
out and spread the word there is so much
more to be done we are never going to be
done in this fight so if you haven't yet
if you've been listening to this all
this time if you've been listening and
you have not clicked the link in the
description below what are you waiting
for
well could you be waiting for the right
moment the right opportunity the right
moment is now the right opportunity is
now please I'm begging you please just
click the link down there and subscribe
to PewDiePie and if I could give any of
you some homework to do
text a friend text some misguided soul
that is in your life someone who doesn't
see the light doesn't see the wisdom
doesn't see anybody as great as the man
that PewDiePie is text them right now
with gentle words of kindness reach out
to them and say friend Oh friend of mine
have you subscribed to PewDiePie yet
have you done your part let the guilt
weigh on their soul and their soul alone
let them think about the sins of their
life let them know and then bring up the
eternal question of their horrible
horrible horrible taste and YouTube
channels ask them with a follow up text
or they subscribe to T series and if
they are then I'm sorry you must lose
that friend
I know it's drastic I know it sounds bad
I know it sounds bad but much like the
Inquisition we must purge the heretics
we must know who among us would have
taste that terrible we must know because
you just can't have someone in your life
that is subscribed to T series you can't
it's a sad truth of this world but it is
survival of the fittest and the fittest
cannot be subscribed to T series no no
and it's a tragedy to lose a friend like
that but if you think about it they were
never your friend in the first place if
they've been subscribed to T series
they've been they've been holding back
on you they've been letting you know
something about them that was a lie and
you can't have Liars in your life No
we must know the truth we must see the
light and you need to go into the
description right now and click the link
to subscribe to PewDiePie right now
don't wait right now do it do it do it
there's a convenient link right there
and I'll like I've said before but I'll
say again for anybody that it didn't get
through to if you're not logged into
YouTube go login right now click that
button to subscribe to Beauty pie please
this is more than us
this is bigger than all of us this is
bigger than anyone here
this is bigger than everyone in this
stream this is bigger than everyone on
YouTube this goes so far beyond just
YouTube this is for the heart and soul
of the entire Internet we can't have
this we can't because I don't want to
speak in doomsday prophecies I don't I
don't want to be cataclysmic about it
but there is a possibility there is a
tangible possibility and as slim as it
may be there is a tangible possibility
that t-series will pass PewDiePie but
not on our watch not on our watch not
while we still have air in our lungs not
while we have still fingers that can
click on subscribe buttons no not today
not now not ever not on our watch
this is our fight this is our war we are
all part of it whether we want to be or
not and you need to do your part click
the link in the description below right
now and if you don't have a youtube
channel make one if you have a friend
that doesn't have a youtube channel get
them to make one they need to make one
immediately you
to recruit as many people as possible
who don't have a YouTube channel and
give them to make one and as soon as
they do you know the channel that they
should subscribe to first in fact maybe
you do have a friend that does have a
YouTube channel and maybe they have said
that oh they might have subscribed to
PewDiePie why don't you go over to their
house see how they're doing watch some
fun YouTube videos with them and then
when they take a trip to the bathroom
browse their subscription feed and I
swear if you see T series in their sub
box you need to get out of that house
and you need to run you need to run and
you need to run you need to leave town
because they are coming for you they
brought you over to that house for a
reason and it wasn't for safety it
wasn't for friendship they are not your
friend they are not anyone that you need
to be anywhere associated with but
before you leave I know it's terrifying
I know it's a terrifying scenario to be
in that I know I know I know I know it's
a terrifying situation to be in but you
need to be brave you need to be brave
I'm asking you to be brave for one more
moment you need to be brave before you
leave that house before you abandon your
life before you abandon your family
before you abandon that friend of yours
you need to do two things you need to
unsubscribe them from T series yes it's
dangerous but you need to do that and
then please before you leave you need to
hit the subscribe button to PewDiePie's
channel you have to if you don't there's
no hope there's no hope for any of us if
we are not brave enough to stand up to
those who would do us wrong damn it I
can't deal with that right now then who
are we are we cowards
are we cowards no we are not click that
link in the description below we won't
stand by for this because we are not
cowards we are brave brave brave brave
brave brave nine-year-olds and we are
willing to go the distance to make sure
that what is right is done in this world
so go now in the description click that
link go to PewDiePie's channel subscribe
subscribe subscribe subscribe and spread
the word as far and wide as you possibly
can make sure that everyone does their
part there is no end to this fight I
know and that can seem like a daunting
task but remember the wise words of a
man that I've forgotten the name of do
your part and evil can never win so do
your part and do your part to make sure
that T series never ever passes
PewDiePie in subs this reminds me of a
story that I was told once not when I
was a young child but just recently over
in the past few years an old man with a
long gray beard once said to me son you
have a friend mm-hmm you who you will be
called upon to help him I said can I
hear old man why are you in my house and
I didn't listen that day no I didn't
listen that day at all if I only tried
sooner if you only tried sooner maybe we
wouldn't be in such a desperate
situation right now maybe this gap
wouldn't be so close but it's never too
late to try you may think that all the
light is out of the world and darkness
has overtaken everything but know there
is light at the end of the tunnel
there's lights beyond the horizon there
is light waiting for us there is hope
there is love there is a destiny waiting
for us it doesn't matter if you think
it's too late you can still try it's
still worth
trying and you have to try so click that
link in the description below right now
and remember if you don't have an
account what are you even doing on
YouTube who are you watching t series
are you in incognito mode right now
watching huh
are there people in this stream that are
watching incognito but if you actually
log in your subscribe to T series I
think we have secret agents in this chat
right now that are helping t Series win
there's no way that this gap would ever
ever ever shrink if we weren't all
united to the cause we have to find
these people if you're loyal to this
cause shout it out in chat right now I
am loyal and anyone else any spies
around here anyone in this place that is
subscribed to T series I say right now
run you run as far away as you can
you are not welcome here there there's
the loyalty there's the loyalty anyone
here that is subscribed to T sirs you
run as far away as you can
you are not welcome here no we here are
loyal to the true king and we will make
sure no matter what no matter the
circumstances no matter how many enemies
are lurking in our myths that we do our
part so click that link in the
description below right now it's so easy
let me psychically move your mouse down
oh there yes Oh to the right and click
it's up to you now I've moved your mouse
over to the link you have to click
though I can't make that leap for you
you have to click and you have to
confirm and if you somehow magically
weren't affected by my psychic powers to
make your mouse move down then go to
youtube.com slash PewDiePie and
scribe to the man the myth the legend
PewDiePie I'm sorry I'm getting
emotional about this because this
impacts me deeply very very deeply when
I was a young boy my first word that I
ever spoke was PewDiePie it's true
that's a fact
I never lie I said earlier I never lie
and I never lie I didn't know what that
meant my family didn't know what that
meant no one around me knew what that
meant but even in my heart of hearts I
think two-year-old me knew that there
was a destiny and a call and awaiting me
there was something on the horizon that
was greater and brighter than anything I
could have ever hoped for and that was
knowing that one account on YouTube
would always stay above another in terms
of subscriptions but it cannot be done
by one baby by himself no matter how
handsome a baby I was no matter how
muscular I was no matter how incredibly
talented I was as a baby I am just one
man I was just one baby babies we are
millions of babies strong and we
millions of babies can do move mountains
we can do move mountains
we're just babies we don't know how to
make sentences we can do move mountains
babies unite to do move mountains
but sadly not all his joys we're
surrounded by traders we're surrounded
by enemies we're surrounded by those who
do not do their part we're surrounded by
those that are willing to stay by the
wayside those that are willing to just
oh I'll watch this parade of tragedy
pass me by there are those that are
willing to just stand idly by on the
sidelines as tragedy strikes and I say
no you are either with us or you are
subscribed to t-series and there is one
that is right and there is one that is
wrong and I say to you where do you
stand and whines hmm do you stand on the
line with a million babies who can do
move mountains huh where do you stand do
you know someone who's not doing their
part do you know any youtuber that's not
doing their part do you know anyone with
even a single follower on any social
media platform that is not doing their
part I say to you the time is now let
them know their sins let them know the
wrong that they have done no one is just
an observer in this fight no one stands
on the sidelines we are all in this
together or we all fall together go now
tell everyone you know they need to do
their part they need to subscribe to
PewDiePie use the link that I provided
in the description below it's so
convenient it's so elegant it's so easy
right there down in the description or
maybe it's over there somewhere but
click that link right click it hit copy
go to Twitter paste write a little blurb
say a million babies can do move
mountains and let the world know that
you cannot goddamnit my other bottle I
can't deal with that now
let them know that this fight is so much
more than the sum of our total parts we
need all linked arms as a million babies
and we need to play the world's biggest
game of Red Rover versus those
disgusting freaks that would subscribe
to t-series Red Rover Red Rover calling
the traders over but we are strong we
are linked long and we will never break
the chain because we are united in one
passionate circle of trust and love and
no one can break us apart so go now tell
the world tell everyone you know spread
it far and wide tell your parents
because they may be secret t-series
traders - yes I'm sorry I didn't know if
I wanted to bring this up but I have to
bring this up your parents they can't be
trusted
they're not tech savvy they may even
have a youtube account but you have to
look through them even I'm sorry they
may be browsing parts of the Internet's
that they shouldn't some of your parents
might be subscribing t-series and I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry if that is the
world that you live in but you need to
Bri brave you need to be a brave baby
you need to be a brave baby you need to
be a brave baby right now and you need
to go log into your parents YouTube
channel and see who they're subscribed
to and if they're not subscribed to
PewDiePie do yourself a favor and do
them a favor click on that subscribe
button click on that link down the
description right there below and make
sure that they are subscribed to
PewDiePie but if the worst comes to pass
I'm sorry if this is the reality but if
the worst comes to pass
if the worst comes to pass and your
parents are subscribed to t-series you
got disown them it's probably the
hardest goodbye that you'll ever need to
say but they just can't be trusted they
just can't be trusted
and even you'll have to question your
entire childhood you'll have to question
your entire way of upbringing because
you'll have to look and all the things
that you've done in your life you'll
have to think back at all the lessons
that they've taught you and you'll have
to look at how tainted they've made your
own life parents subscribe to t-series
can't raise children well I'm sorry I
know this is harsh I know it's hard but
you need to be brave you need to be
brave you have to you have to but before
you obviously unsubscribe them to see
series and disown them as parents you
have to subscribe them to PewDiePie you
have to you must you must
I know it's hard I know we were scared I
know you feel alone but you're not alone
we are seventy-three plus million strong
and Counting we can do move mountains
together
and you will do your part because you
will have netted one for PewDiePie and
negative 140 series and I have to do a
check again I'm sorry we have to do a
check
I need a loyalty check right now in chat
right now right now no waiting you type
out right now if you're loyal are you
loyal say I am loyal in chat if you are
subscribed to beauty pie and if you're
not we have ways of making you subscribe
to PewDiePie we have ways of making you
unsubscribe from t-series so yes yes we
do oh yes we do there we are
there's the loyalty there's the loyalty
well if you're so loyal then why don't I
see tweets god damn it my other bottle I
can't deal with that right now well if
you're so loyal then why haven't you
done enough there is always more that
you can do and I am sorry to yell at you
but I need to knock some sense in you
listen to me if you're watching this
passively look at night look at my eyes
look at my eyes look at my eyes look me
in the eye get one friend right now to
subscribe to PewDiePie I want to see one
more person from every single person
looking me in the eyes right now it
doesn't stop with you know you think I'm
stopping with just me as great as I am
as muscular as I am as slightly average
hided as I am you think that I'm just
doing this alone no no no no no I do my
part and your part extends beyond just
you I demand one more from all of you
and it's as simple as going down into
the description below clicking that link
copying in and pasting it everywhere you
know the bye bye man don't think it
don't speak it well it's time to think
it
it's time to think it it's time to speak
in the pewdiepie man needs to be spread
as far and wide as possible on the
internet so please spread that link copy
it text it to every friend that you have
we're gonna multi-level market this
[ __ ] we're gonna get everybody by sheer
numbers into the light because it's
what's right it's not spam if it's right
and if it's for the fight of our lives
so please do your part yes yes yes yes
we can do move mountains yes yes yes yes
there we are
I've made it as simple as I possibly
could I've made it as simple as I
possibly could and I can't spell it out
anymore simply but my god I'm going to
try excuse me I'm thirsty did you do it
did you text your friends did you text
your family members why not why haven't
you is there anybody in this stream that
has not subscribed to PewDiePie can
there possibly be anybody in this stream
right now that has not subscribed to
PewDiePie why why do you want the world
to be cast in darkness why do you want
all of society to collapse why do you
want t-series to win why who are you
look yourself in the mirror and ask
yourself the honest question who are you
do you even know do you even understand
I don't think you do
if you haven't clicked the link at the
description below and subscribe to
PewDiePie what are you are you even
human I question that
but I feel like you can I feel like you
have an opportunity I feel like you have
a moment to take advantage of this one a
shining beacon of light that's left in
our world this one moment you don't want
to live in regret for the rest of your
life knowing that you didn't take the
chance right now now now now now now
among all other times now now is the
time now is the moment now is the one
moment that we can make a difference now
is the one moment we can make the world
better but it has to be now it has to be
now it has to be now and if you are and
I know there are many people that are
subscribed to PewDiePie but have you
texted your grandma yet have you have
you texted your granny to subscribe to
PewDiePie just do it
if you text her a link she'll click it
you'll click anything she trusts you and
you're right so know that you are not
spamming your grandma you are helping
her see the light copy the link in the
description below and text it to your
grandma right now right now let her know
the truth let her know the light let her
know that we are in this fight together
let her know but as I've said before you
have to check
you have to check to make sure that
she's not subscribed to PewDiePie and
it's a tough it's a tough check this
one's real hard losing a friend
disowning your parents they're nothing
compared to leaving grandma I know but
you have to be brave we promised each
other you made a promise to me that you
would be brave say it and shout right
now say that you're brave are you brave
are you brave say that you're brave say
that you're a big brave baby and you are
gonna check to see if your grandma's
subscribe to t-series and if she is
unsubscribe that [ __ ] right then in
there and then subscriber to PewDiePie
because it's what must be done because
we are brave we are strong and we are
loyal and we will never forget what's
right so go down in that description
right now click the link that says
subscribe to PewDiePie click it click it
it's the easiest thing in the world
click it and then tell the world spread
the news as far and as wide as you can
spread the word subscribe to PewDiePie
this reminds me of a story when I was a
young lad I was once playing video games
and I entered a cheat code and I didn't
realize what that cheat code meant I
didn't know the cheat code was a
scrambled word of letters and numbers
but looking back I can see it clearly
with my photographic memory subscribe to
PewDiePie
yes even 9 year old me playing video
games trying to cheat in video games
knew what must be done I did it's true I
know and I did it but I didn't do it
then don't let the messages that are
bleeding in through the cracks in
reality skin
you buy these messages that you're
hearing they are the truth they are the
only thing that matters they are the
people around you screaming cuz you're
in a coma right now wake up wake up
t-series is about to pass Beauty bite so
wake up subscribe to PewDiePie right now
you need to wake up you need to wake up
this is a nightmare
that we cannot stay in forever and the
only way to wake up from this nightmare
is to subscribe to PewDiePie right now
look in the description there's a link
down there sub to PewDiePie click on
that link right now I mean it cuz just
imagine just imagine a world where we
have a series above I know it's hard
I know it's a horse thought I know it's
terrifying
I know it's scared but we are brave we
are strong imagine the chaos imagine the
devastation imagine the nightmares
imagine what will happen to society will
crumble the Earth's crust will crack
magma will erupt life as we know it will
be over
there will be no hope there'll be no
memes article 13 will be passed the
internet will be put behind pay a wall
after pay wall after pay a wall all of
the content and you know in love will be
gone original content just won't exist
it's a terrible world but we can change
it that future is not set in stone much
like terminator we can change the fate
that we make the make we fate the fate
is what we make it that's what Sarah
Connor said and when we make fate the
fate that we make is the fate that we
have and the fate is not written the
fate we make is not yet written that we
make the fate and we're gonna write the
fate and the fate that we make is gonna
write itself when we subscribe to
PewDiePie so do it
do it now click that link in the
description below make sure that you're
doing your part text that link to
everybody you know everyone in your
family everyone at school if you're
watching this and you're in school I
don't know where the hell you are we're
in school on a Sunday but the teachers
might be subscribed to t-series in fact
I don't think you can trust anyone
that's in your life at all no I don't
think you can trust anybody you can only
trust the people that are subscribed to
PewDiePie so trust us the millions of
babies we can't do move mountains we are
brave we are strong and we are loyal I'm
afraid that I must leave you soon yes
they're coming for me
speaking out is dangerous I know I'll
have to move I don't know when I'll be
able to make videos again but know that
I did my part
if I go down fighting keep fighting to
the last never give up never ever
surrender never ever give up this fight
isn't over with me this fight isn't over
with you know
this fight will carry on for generations
this legacy will last on and on and on
and on but we must keep fighting
we can't do mountains of subscribers
over to PewDiePie so with my parting
words with my parting words go down into
that description click the link right
there
I've made it so simple I've made it as
easy as I possibly can't click that link
and do your part
subscribe to PewDiePie let the world
know what must be done before I go I
want to tell you one more story when I
was in school that was only just
starting to use the Internet
but I saw I saw a banner ad just a small
one
it said subscribe to T Sears and I
destroyed that computer I burnt it to
the ground and then I never saw it again
cuz I knew the face of evil as soon as I
saw it and it looks like this this right
here that logo is the face of evil it's
true pure evil and I knew that evil must
be beaten so thank you everybody so much
for watching
spread the word far and wide spread that
link far and wide and as always bye bye
[ __ ] yeah whatever